>>> Marjorie Taylor Greene, the
Republican congresswoman from
Georgia, re-elected in November,
has pushed baseless qanon lies
and conspiracies saying
Democrats and celebrities are
part of a satan-worshipping
pedophile ring.
She has since tried to walk back
her involvement in qanon.
She also questioned the events
of 9/11, something she's also
tried to walk back.
>> The so-called plane that
crashed into the Pentagon, it's
odd there is never any evidence
shown for a plane in the
Pentagon.
There is an islamic invasion
into our government offices
right now.
Kennedy getting killed in the
plane crash, that's another one
of those Clinton murders, right?
>> So she has pushed conspiracy
that mass shootings were staged
and false flag events including
called a parkland survivor a
paid actor.
She engaged in antisemitic and
anti-muslim rhetoric, compared
Barack Obama to Osama bin laden,
compared mask rules in congress
to the holocaust before she
entered congress.
Also liked social media comments
calling for the executions of
democratic politicians including
Nancy Pelosi, Hillary Clinton
and Barack Obama.
Her list included FBI agents.
She posted a picture of herself
holding a gun alongside pictures
of three members of the
so-called squad with the caption
she was going on, quote, offense
against these socialists.
In 2019 and 2020 she encouraged
protesters to, quote, flood the
capitol and endorse political
violence claiming that 2020
election was stolen from Donald
Trump and in the past two months
she has downplayed the
insurrection against a symbol of
American democracy, her very own
workplace.
>> And I have to tell you
something.
Steve Bannon and I would have
organized that, we would have
bon.
Not to mention it would have
been armed.
>> Wow!
Woo!
>> Yeah.
See, that's the whole joke,
isn't it?
>> She says that she would have
won the insurrection on January
6th with arms.
The same insurrection she blamed
on antifa and yesterday in the
same capitol this was attacked
on that same house floor that
was breached by many now
convicted criminals, Marjorie
Taylor Greene sat in for the
house speaker and presided over
the house, gavel in hand, the
same house she says that she
could have seized during an
insurrection.
A sad day for America.
Here to discuss Adam Kinsinger,
Melissa and mondir.
Good morning.
Having just heard that, where is
the lie?
>> You don't know where to start
with that.
Marjorie Taylor Greene has just
uniquely kind of decided to take
on every conspiracy theory
imaginable.
It would be funny if it wasn't
so scary.
Sometimes you look at the things
she says and you are like this
is so out there.
This is a woman who doesn't
believe basic facts about our
history in the speaker's chair,
as I was watching that very good
interview by kaitlan Collins
with comer and I had to say
something because he is citing
sources that are credible, not
credible, talking about facts
that are flexible and maybe you
believe one thing and maybe
another.
Facts are facts.
This is where we are right now.
I wander if you are happy to be
out of it?
>> I am really happy to be out
of there.
It's sad to me.
I know Mr. Comer.
He is a good guy.
I was kind of surprised by the
turn he has taken as the chair
of the house oversight
committee.
Hunter Biden's laptop, maybe the
FBI has an interest in that.
His laptop was stolen from him
and exposed to people.
He is not in government.
Yet this is the Republican's
number one thing this year.
So my political analyst hat says
James comer this, Marjorie
Taylor Greene is very
influential person in the party.
If I take that off and speak as
Adam Kinzinger, what she says is
what a lunatic says.
It's finding every conspiracy
and taking the trust of the
American people.
You represent 700,000 people but
you have a voice in front of
hundreds of millions and you are
telling them complete and utter
lies for one reason, so you can
be promoted in this low paying
job that you have in comparison
to other things.
>> What about the line sadly
crossed, fringe conspiracy
theory, when qnon was not widely
espoused by some in power and
government to being repeated by
people like Marjorie Taylor
Greene?
I mean, you have years ago what
happened in D.C. In the pizza
shop, pizzagate and then these
neo-nazis planning an attack on
Baltimore.
Lies lead to actual violence and
can lead to death.
>> Absolutely.
These comments are not just made
and nothing happens in response
to them.
We saw an attack or attempted
attack on the city of Baltimore.
Well, it turns out a few years
ago Donald Trump himself in
attacking Elijah Cummings --
>> And the city itself.
>> Majority black city, quote,
disgusting, rat-infested and a
place no one would want to live.
Fast forward a few years.
A neo-nazi and his ally, I
guess, attempting to disrupt
life in the city of Baltimore.
For one reason only, I think.
>> Everybody every day when you
wake up you have a battle in
your heart between, like, I will
call it good and evil.
Light and darkness.
You always kind of have to dark
that.
It's easy to let the dark parts
of your heart overtake your
thinking.
You don't have to think too
hard.
All your fear can manifest into
how you act.
When somebody in power, in
leadership, stands in front of
you and speaks out the dark
parts of your heart, it gives
you permission to let that
overtake you.
A leader's job is not to do
that.
A leader's job is to avoid the
temptation.
>> You said I think, don, are
you happy to be out of there.
You said you are so happy.
Recognizing what that moment is
because you fought so hard
against that while you were
there and realizing, I think,
you couldn't change it enough?
>> Yeah.
Look, to abextent I am sad I
don't have the ability to fight
there.
I am personally glad to be out.
It was 12 years.
You have to say are from my
party, I don't think it's going
to take just one person coming
along and saying the right
things.
This thing has to burn through
the party.
There has to be a moment where
people are like, this doesn't
work anymore.
>> There is a similarity between
us and that because when I was
on the night show every day it
was a knife fight about you are
wrong, whatever.
So this is a -- because I
thought it would be -- there is
a different conversation you
could have.
It's very easy, as you said,
this fight in your heart to be
lulled into the idea that -- and
to normalize what comer said, to
what Marjorie Taylor Greene
said, and that people actually
believe it.
The American people are going to
have to deal with this for at
least the next four years about
what's real and what's not.
And --
>> Yeah, you were in the white
house.
>> You said don't be lulled into
this sort of false narrative
that trump has been -- he is
different because he has been
investigated.
You said that's bs?
>> We were talking about how
many Republicans and former
government officials we know who
we, you know, are honest decent
people and now they are doing
things that are performative and
they know better.
Comer I would put into that box.
He said Donald Trump has been
investigated for five years.
Two years ago he helped incite
an insurrection on the U.S.
Capitol.
The idea that there is a date of
expiration on it is absurd.
I like the point that Adam made.
This is a crucial moment for the
country.
When are people going to put
doing what's right for the
country ahead of their political
ambition or future ambitions?
Feels like so many people,
whether it's a Marjorie Taylor
Greene or Lauren boebert, they
are running for the cable news
gig, not to serve the people of
the districts or the people of
the country.
It's terrible and we are going
to look back and be like, what
are we doing?
>> What do people do?
Step away like you?
Do they step away like you?
Find a different route to tell
the story, tell the truth?
>> The beginning is having
conversations with people you
disagree.
We are on different sides of the
aisle but let's talk about what
a Democrat and a Republican
could marginally agree on.
>> It's incumbent upon the media
to educate the public about
facts, which should not be in
dispute.
Unfortunately because of changes
in the media environment you
have too many networks in this
country focused on pushing the
same lies that you see from even
James comer to say nothing of
Donald Trump and other people
who are like him.
>> Could I say that the bible
says you can't point out a speck
in somebody's eye when you have
a plank in your own.
There is benefit, whoever you
are, recognize your own issues,
right?
This Chinese balloon, every
Republican is saying Biden needs
im he impeached over this, which
is insane.
The Democrats when solemone was
killed, they were wanted to
start World War III in the
Middle East.
Recognize that.
Look, our side has had some
inconsistencies.
Right now I got to tell you the
Republicans own this
inconsistencies thing.
Standing in front and saying